Okay, guys, welcome to the call.
Today we're going to be talking about sub-nitching.
We've been talking a lot about niches.
We've been talking a lot about picking the right city.
Basically the first step in the process, which I believe is the most important process apart
from the sales and getting the deal and getting people to give you their money, this is the
very most important part of the entire process.
This is one of the, I think, what is the date?
It's August 12th.
We're really focusing in this quarter on this first step, and so if it seems like we're
going very nuanced, it's because we are, and that is because I know when I say it, when
you first hear about this model, it's like, okay, pick a city, pick a niche, rank the
website, rank it out.
Boom, that's the 20,000-foot view, and that is actually true.
However, you'll realize that all the money is in these tiny little adjustments.
It's in that 10%.
It's the difference between making a million dollars a year and making $10,000 a year is
in the nuance.
We are talking about nuance.
Today we're going to be talking about specifically sub-nitching so that you guys can, and so
I'm going to get into what we're going to cover and all that kind of stuff, but we're
going to be talking about sub-nitching inside of picking your perfect niche for whatever
project, whatever industry you decide to go into.
Okay, so hold on.
Can everybody hear me, by the way?
You can hear me, right?
Yeah, you're good.
Okay.
I got another notification that said this meeting was being recorded, so I didn't know
if that was an error or what.
Okay, guys, what I'm going to do, give me one second.
I'm going to just open this window.
Hold on.
Get some light in here.
Okay, you can still hear me, Aaron?
Absolutely.
Beautiful.
Okay, Aaron's going to be in charge of letting people in.
He's also going to be in charge of kicking people out.
He's going to be in charge of comments, questions, et cetera, and I'm going to leave time for
questions because I think that we've gotten in the last, this is our sixth week doing
this, right, Aaron?
Yeah, that our seventh.
Okay, this is our seventh.
It might be.
I got to count.
Okay, sixth or seventh, and we have had really, really good questions from these groups because
basically what these groups consist of is the people inside of the free group, the ones
that are actually serious about taking actions, the ones that actually want to go and make
some money and do something and don't just want to listen, they want to apply.
We have had really, really good questions that we're going to save some time for, okay?
Want to remind everybody that if you guys keep your cameras on and stay to the end,
we're going to take everything that we covered today and we're going to turn it into a digital
resource and we're going to just DM you guys from Donnie Dre.
He's going to DM you the digital resource.
I'm not going to have to comment anywhere, poke, whatever.
You're going to just automatically get it by staying on this call till the end and keeping
your camera on.
Okay, so that's number one, and what we're going to do is at the end, Aaron is going
to screenshot everybody that's on this call, okay?
Again, make sure your camera's on.
We're not trying to be weird, but we want to make sure that the people that are on are
actually on and we have that good energy, we have that good participation when it was
having a bunch of dead weight.
Okay, I'm a big fan of not having dead weight.
That's the whole reason that we're doing this on Zoom rather than doing it in Facebook,
okay?
So that said, guys, let's get into this really, really quick.
Aaron, does it look like we have anybody new?
In fact, what I want to do as we get started, I want to know really quick, is there anybody
in the comments, is anybody ... No, actually, it's what I want to do.
In the comments, I want to know how many calls you've been on since we changed the format.
Since we went to doing Zoom calls, these intimate Zoom calls, I want to know how many calls
have you actually been on?
Is this your first put one, if it's your third put three, if it's your fifth put five, if
it's whatever.
I want to know really quick, and then Aaron, I want you to start reading and let me know
so I kind of have an idea how many calls everyone's been on.
Yeah.
This is the second one for Todd, first one for Trey, first one for Christopher, fourth
for Shane.
He's been with us for a while.
Jaleel, it's the second one, Jen's the third, Elden's the first, Jose's the first, Theo's
the third, and then Matthew's likely my eighth, so yeah, Matthew's been hanging with us.
So yeah, we got a couple people though for their first.
Is that Matthew Torres?
Yeah.
Okay, girl, dope.
So I was going to actually ... My next question was, and going to let everybody know, any
of you, I think there's one or two I heard, maybe just one, maybe it's Matthew, but if
you are in digital landlords, you are going to get these recordings regardless.
I'm glad you're on these live because I think it's good.
You can ask questions, whatever, however, you're going to get these recordings inside
of the training material as well.
So just heads up.
Okay.
The reason I wanted to ask is I wanted to know how familiar people are with me.
So really, really quick, I like to start every call with a one-minute synopsis of just my,
I guess my pedigree, my credibility here.
I don't think you should listen to anybody on the internet personally.
I think you should assume everybody's full of crap, but for what it's worth, my name's
Nick Wood.
I've been doing this since 2016.
I had a little nine-month period where I chased shiny pennies.
I lost a bunch of money doing software or trying to do software, and it woke me up and
showed me just how good this business model was.
And sometimes you have to lose everything to realize what you have, which is true in
every single facet of life.
That's what happened to me.
And out of necessity, I either had to get a job to pay for my bills and take care of
my family, or I had to start doing this.
And I choose this every single day of the week.
Anyway, I lost a lot of money.
I've spent over about a million and a half dollars on Google ads alone.
I went $60,000 in debt.
I've had companies go bankrupt on me that owed me $15,000 plus.
I've hired and fired the wrong people.
I've gotten office space, and I shouldn't have gotten office space.
I made it through COVID.
I have almost quit twice.
I've gone into the wrong niches.
I've gone into the wrong sub-niches.
I've built over 200 websites, half of which were in the wrong niches.
I have done just about everything wrong that you can imagine.
And also, on the other hand, in 2020, I finally figured this out.
I figured out how to scale.
I figured out the missing pieces of this business model.
And we scaled this business to $100,000 per month, and we haven't looked back since.
Just over seven figures in 2020 did over $1.4 million in 2021.
And then we haven't looked back since then as well.
And I tell you that so that as I'm talking to you, you're not sitting here going, who
is this guy?
Is this another person that's just talking?
You should assume that.
But I want you to also know that I don't speak, for example, today what we're talking about,
this is all going to be from experience.
And I'm going to go over kind of our game plan of what we're going to be talking about
here in just a moment.
And so you guys have an outline.
But this is only from experience.
And if I haven't done it, I'm going to tell you, and I do this because this is what I
wish that I had.
I wish that somebody who was basically five years ahead of me or millions of dollars ahead
of me could have been on a live and I could have asked them questions.
I could have asked them about this niche and that niche and what do you think about this
and what about running ads and what about scaling and who do you hire?
What about outsourcing and all these different things that I never knew.
And I would ask these questions, guys, to these groups that I was a part of.
But nobody in these groups had done what I wanted to do.
And I'm a huge proponent, a huge believer that if you have not done what I want to do,
I cannot listen to you.
I'll listen to you out of respect if I have to come in the room with you, but I'm not
going to take your advice.
OK, I'm not going to take advice from a trainer who doesn't have the body that I want.
I'm not going to take advice from a financial planner who doesn't have the the bank account
that I want and the investment portfolio that I want.
I'm not going to take marriage advice from somebody that doesn't have a thriving marriage,
somebody that I'm not going to do that.
And so I want you guys to know, as I'm talking on this call, I am somebody that's done this
and I've now trained over six hundred and seventy people to do this, one of which, Mr.
Ryan Dalton, who just barely got into this two years ago, I'm happy to say, is making
over seventy five thousand dollars per month.
I think is absolutely incredible.
He's also got two kids, a wife, a dog, hobbies and everything else.
So any excuse that you have for why you can't do this is an excuse.
OK, that's just the truth.
When I started this, it wasn't good time.
OK, it's never good timing.
I'm just going to let you guys know if you haven't started and you're waiting for the
perfect time, then hop off the call right now because it's not going to ever be good
timing. It's never good timing to do anything.
It's never good timing to get married, never good timing to have a kid, never good timing
to start a business or to take that opportunity or do anything.
And you're going to realize that you only get a couple of chances in life to like good,
good chances of opportunities.
And if you don't get in the habit of taking advantage of those, then you're you're you're
going to look back with regret.
And if you think that the timing is going to be perfect, you're crazy.
OK, when I started this business, I was knocking doors full time.
I had it. I was managing a team of 20 people with with a friend of mine.
So every single day I was knocking doors during the day, doing meetings until nine,
ten at night. And then I was working on my business during the day or sorry, during the
night. That was my that was my schedule.
So anybody that's sitting here saying I don't have time, whatever, whatever, whatever,
that's not true. OK, so guys, the goal today, my promise to you guys for you guys today
is that I'm going to give you guys enough knowledge on sub niching that you're going to
have the confidence to go into big, hairy, scary niches in a sub niche with a sub niche
angle. And you're going to do so without being worried.
You're going to do so without thinking that you're just going to lose your shorts and
you're going to do so very, very confidently.
That's my promise. The plan today, kind of the outline of what I want to cover over the
next 20 minutes before we get into Q&A is number one, I want to talk about what is sub
niching. OK, number two is I want to talk about why I think you should always err on
the side of sub niching, even with the non-competitive niches.
And I'm going to get into that throughout this.
OK, I also want to talk about how my screw ups led me to figure out sub niching and
they forced me to figure out sub niching.
I'm going to give you guys some examples on sub niching.
We're going to talk about how there's always a sub niche angle, easy ways to find sub
niches. And finally, I'm going to give you an example of one of my sub niche websites.
And then we're going to do some Q&A.
OK, so that said, I want you guys, if you have questions, I want you to start dropping
them right now because I am going to go rapid fire, get through as many as possible.
Last time we did a really good job and we got through a ton of questions.
I don't think there was any question that we didn't get through.
So, Aaron, while I'm turning down the AC, like I always do and I forget to do, will
you please see if there's any comments really quick?
Give me one second. All right is.
Think we should all invest in an auto air conditioner adjuster app or something for
that, because literally every single week.
But, you know. OK, was there any comments?
No, we're ready to just get to it.
Let's do it. OK, let's do this thing, guys.
So let's talk about sub niching really quick.
I'm not going to waste time on stuff.
It doesn't matter. Sub niching is taking a big niche and going into something that is
more narrow. OK, it's it's and we always hear the riches are in the niches.
And that is true.
And the thing that you don't realize when you get into this is everyone thinks of like
these big niches that are top of mind, HVAC, roofing, plumbing, solar, blah, blah,
blah, blah, blah. Right.
Everyone has I get if you know how many times someone's messaged me and said, hey,
what do you think about getting solar leads or what about this?
I would be very, very, very rich, very rich because everyone asks the same questions.
And the truth is, as I've said before, you can get you can get leads in any niche.
I've got them in assisted living.
I've got assisted living leads.
I've gotten golf lesson leads.
I've gotten cactus removal leads.
I've gotten the weirdest type of leads you could ever imagine.
You can get leads.
I've got them in alarm systems.
We've got them in tax tax returns, CPA stuff.
The the thing is, it's not black and white.
Which is the case with anything in life, right?
It's not are you going to get leads or not?
You will get leads. It's how many leads?
How how how is the juice worth the squeeze?
And so no matter what industry you go into, eventually you do enough of what we teach.
You're going to get leads.
The question becomes, is it the best use of time?
And so some of these big, scary niches, these roofing, these these
plumbing, these, you know, these bigger ones, everyone wants to mention,
even like electrician, whatever.
They're not the move.
They're landscaping.
They're too, too, too, too, too competitive.
However, if you go sub niche, there's a lot of money.
And so what I want to say is, yes, there's money in there's riches in the niches.
But in my opinion, you know, I've said this, I said this last call.
There's there's riches in the the niche cities or the boring cities
or the cities that no one thinks about.
Right. And the boring niches.
But there's also a lot of money in the sub niches.
And so that's what we're going to be discussing today.
So some niche is basically just an offshoot of a niche.
So think, for example, we'll give you I'll give you an example.
Roofing and roof repair.
OK, roofing is the general niche.
There are companies that do roofing like they go and they do roof replacements.
That's where the big money's at for a lot of these companies.
I have a buddy that's making millions of dollars in Myrtle Beach.
A friend of mine, I know from Africa, actually,
and he grew up here as well, making millions of dollars doing roofing.
There's a lot of money in roof replacements.
Insurance pays for it.
It's you know, it's an expensive thing, but it's competitive, man.
It's very, very, very, very competitive.
There's also a lot of money for us in roof repair.
And for these companies, roof repair is not the thing necessarily that everyone wants.
It's not the thing that everyone desires.
But a lot of these companies, when things get a little bit slower,
they want to be able to keep their guys busy.
They want to be able to send their guys out, even if they don't make that much money.
They want to be able to send their guys out, fix a couple.
You know, let's say it's it's a climate like here, Vegas or Phoenix.
We have tile roofs.
Go fix a couple tile.
Boom, two, two, three hundred bucks.
They pay their guy.
They keep them busy while the jobs are coming in.
There are other companies, the smaller guys that will typically take on
just roof repairs, and they're almost more of like a roof handyman.
So anyway, that is what subnitching is.
OK, second thing I want to talk about, and by the way, Aaron,
if you have anything you want to add on any of these points, please let me know.
OK, sounds good.
OK, yeah, like actually real quick, dude, on that, like this was like a year ago
when I first got in the game, totally candid.
I did not end up I this was a I partnered with the dude
and we were doing like some crappy GMB.
He had didn't end up working out in terms of getting a deal.
Like I got a deal for like two weeks, totally collapsed
because the GMB got suspended.
Bottom line, the moral of the story for this context,
I was talking with this roofer dude.
This is like some 50 year old dude, a solo guy who's making bank
because he's charging like 900 bucks to like put a tarp over her roof repair.
So like I firsthand know like roof repair.
It's insane because he's like, honestly, put a lot of times
just put a tarp up and the customer is happy anyway.
Crazy good.
The thing I've learned about this, like talking about subnitches
and all these things is that man, anything that is.
The obvious stuff is never where you want to be
because the obvious stuff is what everyone's doing, right?
And so it always comes down to like, what's everyone doing
and how do I do something different?
Right. Everybody wants to get roofing leads. Right.
Cool. No one wants to go do roof repair leads
because it's not you don't get talked to the big companies and blah,
blah, blah, blah, blah.
But anything that nobody wants to do, there's money in. Right.
There are people right now.
That's what I've learned as I've started to travel the world.
I've met people from tons of different countries,
tons of different ethnicities, tons of different industries.
Guys, I know millionaires in the most weirdest industries
you'd ever imagine in your life.
I know a guy that's very wealthy.
I don't know exactly how wealthy, but this guy is he's a Lebanese guy,
but he's from he's from Sierra Leone, actually,
but he's he throws you off. He's Lebanese.
And this dude is making his money.
By taking garbage, taking plastic,
and and he figured out a way to turn it into cement blocks.
And he's basically it's like 30 percent cheaper. Right.
So instead of just producing seem like a lot of people in Sierra Leone,
they'll go and they'll start an import company. Right.
They'll go and import stuff from Lebanon and import stuff from Turkey.
They'll import stuff from China.
And then they'll they'll sell it to the builders.
They'll sell it to whatever. Right.
And that there's people that make a lot of money doing that.
And it's what this guy did is he's like, hey, instead of going
and doing what everybody else did, I'm actually going to go
and I'm going to I'm going to do building materials,
but I'm going to create a building material out of all the filth on the ground.
And he's he's become very, very successful doing that.
He also has a separate business that he started
where they take I don't know how else to say that they take shit,
human shit from the dump sites.
And they put it in these bags and they literally like
turn it into fertilizer and he sells the fertilizer. Right.
So instead of you could look at the overarching niche being,
you know, garbage collector or waste removal.
And he's gone sub niche and he's he's producing fertilizer. Right.
What I'm getting at is that there are always I think that the move,
no matter what you're doing,
you always want to look for the opportunity to sub niche.
And I don't care if even if you're not in lead generation,
let's say that you do this business, you go and you make ten thousand bucks,
you quit your job, you maybe you make twenty thousand bucks a month.
It allows you to travel and you decide at twenty thousand bucks.
You're going to kind of stop there
and you're going to go pursue some other businesses.
I think you're crazy, but you could.
And, you know, whatever business you get into, I don't care what industry
this is going to be applicable.
I truly, truly, truly believe that no matter what industry
this is going to be applicable for that.
OK, so let me give you an example really quick.
And one thing I want to say is that you do need to make sure
that the volume is adequate.
So you want to go and you want to be sub niche down,
but you have to make sure that the volume is adequate.
Does that make sense?
So, for example, if you're going to go into roof repair in
Las Vegas, Nevada, you need to make sure that even though that's a sub niche,
you need to make sure there's enough volume,
because as you start to go into sub niche,
you're going to start getting less volume than the main niche.
So as long as the volume is adequate, which that's another conversation
for another day of how to discover volume.
That's one of the things we talk about inside the program.
But as long as the volume is adequate, you can never go wrong by sub niching. OK.
I'm going to give you an example that's a little bit outside of this realm,
but it worked amazing.
So in 2021, I started my program, Digital Landlords,
and this is applicable because who knows, maybe one day you guys have your own
programs, maybe not, but this was this is very, very on point. OK.
So I got some coaching from somebody.
This is what I always do.
Whenever I want to do something new, I go find the expert and I pay them.
And in this case, I paid somebody, I think it was ten thousand bucks.
And they had this training that basically showed me how to A to Z, set up my,
you know, how to launch my program.
Imagine they're selling a program on how to sell a program.
What a genius thing to do. But I bought it. It was ten thousand bucks.
I bought it.
And one of the things that this person said is make sure to go niche,
make sure to go very, very, very niche and speak to your exact audience
that you think you're going to be solving the problem for.
And so that's what I did.
And so many of you will never remember this, but when I first started
my program, I called it flat fee mastery. OK.
And the reason I called it flat fee mastery is because at that time,
all the people that I knew, all the people that I knew
that were in this business from other groups, they were people
who had already been in other programs and they knew how to build a website.
They knew how to generate leads.
They just didn't know how to sell.
And specifically, they didn't know how to sell a flat fee deal.
They couldn't even fathom selling a flat fee.
I was getting messages all the time, dude, I can't get anyone
to do anything besides commission.
How are you selling flat fee deals?
So I'm like, dude, I'm going to be teaching people who are already
in other programs, and I'm just going to be teaching the sales side.
I'm not even going to be talking about the SEO.
I'm just going to be talking about sales.
And I'm going to be talking specifically about how to do flat fee.
And so guess what, guys?
I called my program flat fee mastery.
And guess what?
Our free group up until two weeks ago, I think.
When do we change the name of the free group, Aaron?
Just two weeks ago.
Yeah.
A week ago, two weeks ago.
It was called the art of pre-selling.
What does that even mean?
That doesn't even make sense to anyone.
Like, I was the worst name for a group to try to attract people
into this business that have never done it.
The art of pre-selling makes no sense.
It makes total sense, though, if you're already in the business
and you are like, you know, you've built websites,
you've waited six months and you're frustrated, right?
But because I thought I was talking to an audience
that had already been in the space, I didn't care.
Point being, guys, I targeted.
Let me tell you how narrow I went.
And, you know, the first like snitch is I went not just into general business,
but I went into marketing, right?
So there's all kinds of different business and then there's marketing.
But I didn't just go into marketing.
I went into, you know, lead generation specifically
inside the umbrella of marketing, lead generation.
And inside of lead generation, I went into local lead generation.
And inside of locally generation, I went into locally generation using organic.
And inside of that, like there were so many levels.
And inside of that, I went into
specifically flat fee
lead generation by building.
I mean, I was so niche that in my head, I was terrified
because I thought I was going to exclude all these people by going that niche.
And guess what, guys, I did the exact opposite thing.
And when you become when you go niche.
You become the expert, OK?
We've all heard, like, for example,
right now, I'm looking at investing in some property in another country.
And I am having the hardest time
finding somebody that's an attorney or a CPA, not an attorney, a CPA
that specializes or has knowledge and experience
on real estate in another country, specifically in West Africa.
OK, and more to come on that.
But if any of you guys have any ideas of somebody, don't waste my time, please.
But if you do, I'd be really grateful.
The only person that we found, we found one person and they charge
some insane amount of money.
I think it was over a thousand dollars per hour
to just consult, just to consult over some ridiculous.
It was enough that I couldn't even I couldn't even like
I couldn't even wrap my head around.
I'm like, what?
Like, I just need you to tell me if I can depreciate this and if it's the same
and how it's going to look and all this different stuff.
And and and that's that's what happens, guys.
When you become the expert in tiny sub niches,
that's where all the money is. OK, so I would love to see somebody
because I see people all the time on the roofing local.
I'm the lead generator leads for roofing.
I know I haven't seen roof repair lead generator.
OK, I haven't seen that.
I have not seen the roof repair lead generator.
And the reason why is because people are too scared to go sub niche.
But that's where all the freaking money is. OK.
So, Aaron, anything you want to add to that?
No, it's on point. OK, let's keep going.
Real quick, I'm not going to waste too much time on this.
But the reason I got into this, guys, is because I was an idiot.
That's what most most of the stuff I teach you guys,
most of the stuff I've learned is come by me being an idiot
and doing the wrong thing.
And basically what happened to cut a very long, multiple year,
multiple millions of dollars mistake
is I went into industries that were massive and got my butt kicked.
I went into roofing.
I went into I tried alarm systems.
I went into CPA.
I went into a space and waterproofing water.
Oh, my gosh, I got my butt handed to me
out of silver platter and waterproofing foundation repair right there with it.
Landscaping, all of the stuff.
I wouldn't even I wouldn't even waste my time doing a due diligence
on any of these niches.
Like I wouldn't waste five seconds on any of this stuff.
And I built tens.
Of in each of these niches, probably.
I'd say probably over 50 sites in those niches I just mentioned combined.
No more, because just in waterproofing the foundation repair alone, about 50,
I would say close to 100.
In the wrong niches, in these big niches.
So just so you guys know, you don't have to believe me.
You guys can go and see if the stove is hot yourself, because I understand
that's what you have to do sometimes.
But even if you can get that city and you can get that partnership
and you're like, no, I figured it out, guys, we're talking about scaling.
And guess what?
I've also had one or two good partnerships in these industries.
But the point is, it's not repeatable.
It's not something that I can duplicate.
And that's the issue.
OK, so that's that's really the reality is that you guys can either listen
to what I'm saying or you can go try it yourself.
And hopefully you guys are smart enough that you can look at my mistakes and go,
all right, let's just listen to Nick.
OK, that's why I wanted to start off by telling you my my experience
so you didn't have to go touch the stove yourself.
OK, a couple of examples of stub niches.
You know, we could talk about instead of roofing,
we could talk about roof repair instead of landscaping.
There's landscape design instead of electrician.
We could I don't even know what the term for this is,
but you could target just the electrical conversion for electrical vehicles.
I've done it twice in two of my no, I did it once.
Sorry, I got a quote on both houses
and realized my house was already equipped for it because I had an RV garage.
But I've literally called.
I've gone to Google and typed in like Tesla
electrician for Tesla charger electrician for electric car.
Do you know what that's called, Aaron, that conversion process?
I do not. OK, that's exactly right.
That's a niche. That's really sub niche.
And if you go into a big enough city
and you're just getting leads for electric, I mean, I'm sitting here
thinking I shouldn't have said that out loud.
That's a good niche.
Right. The electrical cars are only getting more popular.
I again, I've already had to call.
It's my second time I've had a Tesla and my brother's got one.
I mean, these things are getting in.
It's not just Tesla's now, right?
It's it's all electrical vehicles.
You have to have a special current flowing to the charger to have.
Otherwise, it takes like 24 hours.
It's ridiculous if you just do the regular charger, the 12 volt, whatever.
That's a sub niche inside of electric. I've never done it. OK.
Inside of plumbing, you have what's it called? Sewage.
What am I thinking of, Aaron?
Inside of inside of plumbing, septic, septic removal, I think it is.
Yes, septic tank septic is septic tank removal or septic tank.
Something like that. I know something septic.
I've never done it. I've never done it.
Instead of masonry, you can go into specific things
like block walls, which I'm going to show you today.
Guys, there any niche you're in right now, there's a sub niche.
Inside of inside of concrete, there's two different niches, right?
There's there's flat work, which is what everyone does.
There's decorative, which is what some people do.
And inside of decorative, guess what?
There's another sub niche called cool decking, cool decking.
They go, I did it in my house.
Your your your frickin cement is a million degrees.
Your kids are burning their feet. They come. They lay this nice coat.
They put some flakes on it, kind of looks like an epoxy.
It's called cool decking.
You could just do cool decking leads. And that's two layers deep.
You got concrete, then you got decorative concrete, then you got cool decking.
OK, any niche that you're in that I promise you there's a sub niche.
And that doesn't mean it's always good that, like, for example,
tree service, you could specifically target stump removal.
That's not the move, in my opinion, because stump removal,
there's not that much money in relative to tree service.
But if you were the best at it, and I bet you if you built a stump
removal website, you would outrank the best companies in any city
because nobody's targeting stump removal.
I'd have to run the numbers. I'd have to really figure it out.
And I'm not sure that every company wants stump stump removals.
But that's what I'm saying, guys.
I don't care what it is.
There is an opportunity inside of artificial grass.
There's people that are just searching for artificial grass
for specific things, right? Artificial grass, there's
there's artificial grass for your pets, right?
Pet friendly artificial grass.
Right, there's also a sub niche of of artificial grass.
You know, you could target people that are that are doing like
bigger projects. I wouldn't target big commercial projects,
but you could target different types of projects, right?
You just have to get creative.
Even like fencing, huh?
Like even like fencing, I know that that's kind of starting to get
a bit more popular, kind of an untapped niche, super relevant, obviously.
But like when you think about fencing,
there's like dozens of different types of fences.
So you could go wide, horizontal, right, or vertical and one specific niche
within that niche of chain link fence, wooden fence, barbed wire fence, you know?
Yeah, 100 percent.
Another thing I was thinking of is roofing, right?
So obviously, there's roof repair, but there's also metal roofing.
Right. There's specific roofing.
There's I'm sure there's I don't know what it is after the research,
but I know that Tesla or Sun's
Sun City, is that what it's called?
Is that what it's called? Sun City?
Is that Elon Musk's solar company?
I don't know.
Bro, that's going to bug me.
I think it's Sun City.
Yeah, it is. Hold on.
I just have to, you know.
Everyone wants to know as much as I do.
What is it? Why am I having?
Oh, someone said solar city, I think.
Solar City, Sun City.
Thank you, Discord user.
Discord user, thank you.
Point being, guys, there's always a sub niche, and that's the reality.
OK, so I just want you guys to know if, you know,
we've talked about going vertical like we did last week,
but I want you guys to really consider going sub niche.
Every single niche, there's a sub niche.
I don't care what it is.
I wouldn't do this one.
But for example, I know that there's a niche called cell phone repair.
I promise you that there's a way to go sub niche in that.
You could go with iPhone cell phone repair.
And to be honest, I bet you that there's way more people that do that anyway.
But every single niche, there is a sub niche.
And that, I believe, is where the money's at.
The reason why it's good and where there's a lot of money
in taking big niches and then going sub niche
is because typically the big niches are more competitive
and the sub niches are not.
And when you get into the less known niches and then you sub niche,
the only thing you need to be careful of is you need to make sure
there's adequate search volume.
OK, so real quick, guys, I'm going to share my screen.
I'll show you guys one thing really quick.
And then we're going to Q&A. OK, I'm going to try.
Am I got host, by the way, or cohost, at least.
Aaron.
Sorry, yeah, you should be good now.
OK, let me see. Where the heck did my window go?
Hang tight, brother.
Where's my?
OK, there we go.
All right, let me go ahead and do screen share.
Except for I don't know why it's not letting me got this update on.
Hold on.
All right, there we go.
More. Dude, I don't know why it's not letting me screen share.
Can you I'm cohost for sure, right?
Yeah, and I have all participants enabled for sharing.
Weird, I wonder if it's because I'm inside of Safari,
which I believe is garbage.
It actually doesn't give me the option.
I know you're I know everyone's probably thinking, oh, it's the button.
Every single button I click on, there's not an option to go.
It's weird. You want to send me the link and I'll quickly.
Yeah, you can look it up for me.
So, OK, cool.
What I want to show you guys, well, number one, just go to
go to roofing.
This is I want to show you guys really quick, a quick, easy way
to look at some issues, just kind of like roofing plus a big city.
Do you like roofing?
Chicago, Las Vegas, Las Vegas, Chicago.
Doesn't matter to Chicago.
I'm a Chicago guy. All right.
Go to the top. Organic. All right.
Champion roofing. Beautiful.
I think I've heard of them, but through my research.
And then I want you to just look at the services.
All right. Services.
I hope pop ups for days.
So residential, we got. Oh, man, look at this.
There you go. So you could do roof, you know.
So these guys actually, this is a little bit different
because these guys are going sub niche.
These I technically could argue that these aren't necessarily roofing.
This is some examples, right?
You have roof replacement. That's the big daddy.
You have gutters, which is a sub niche off of roofing.
By the way, I've made a lot of money on gutter installation, gutter cleaning.
There's not a ton of money in.
They're adding masonry in here.
I don't think that's the greatest thing.
Siding is kind of like a whatever.
Let's go to another. Let's go to the next result.
I think these guys are kind of these guys are kind of shiny penny, in my opinion.
But here I ranking number one.
Oh, roof inspections, custom designers.
I didn't think of those that design roof design.
Never thought of that.
Root residential roof repair residents.
They're targeting just residential commercial roof.
I didn't know what that is. Infrared.
I don't know.
And then.
And every single one of these sub niches would shake roof system.
Hilarious metal roof system, slate roof system, clay tile.
Unbelievable. OK, Aaron, I want you to go.
I want to give you guys an example of a quick before we get on this off.
So hold on one second.
You can just keep this window open like this, guys.
One of the very first deals I got when I got back into Legion,
because you guys know that maybe you don't.
But when I got back, I got in this business.
I got a couple of deals. I got shiny penny syndrome.
I, you know, whatever.
And out of necessity, I had to get back into this business.
And I came back and I started doing SEO because I needed quick cash.
And once I realized that SEO wasn't going to scale,
I think it may have been the very first website I ever sold doing regeneration
when I finally realized, oh, my gosh, this is where the money's at.
Was a sub niche of masonry.
So I want you to go and I want you to type in St.
George Block Wall just in the in the let's see how the suckers ranking.
I haven't logged into this in a long time, dude.
All right. St.
George Block Wall.
OK. Oh, still ranking number one.
Hello. Top one.
Let's see me.
I know that I can tell.
Look at this thing. This is a beauty.
OK, so St. George Block Wall.
I built this thing. You can even go to who is go look at who is, bro.
I think it's going to show you. I bought this in 2019.
I think I should have been.
Go look at it really quick. Look me up.
And while you do that, I'm going to get my stripe account
and tell you how much money I've made from this one.
I don't even.
Is it who is domain?
Yeah. Do you have SEO quick on your toolbar?
I don't. OK, don't worry about it.
But anyway, I was going to just prove to you guys that I.
Oh, and I'm not even logged in on Stripe on this computer.
So my laptop, never mind.
I know for a fact, I've made over twenty thousand dollars.
Go back to the website.
Is it right there?
I'd have to figure it out.
I don't know. It's not that relevant.
So go back to the website.
This website right here, dinky freaking website ever has.
I know for a fact, if not, it's probably closer to 30,
but I can with 100 percent confidence say I know it's made me over.
It's made me for sure over twenty thousand dollars. OK.
And you know what the best part about this is, Aaron,
is that the person that I was selling these leads to for twelve hundred dollars
a month for over a year and a half,
they're still paying me for a different set of leads.
But this person ended up joining their part of digital landlords.
The business owner of this of this is a digital landlord.
They decided they're like, dude, I love doing what I do.
They make like I think they make like seven million dollars a year.
Their company does. They don't even do block wall.
They do stucco and they wanted to start learning how to do this
because they wanted to not have to be stuck to their city.
So it's it's it's hilarious how this works.
Anyway, this thing's made me over twenty thousand dollars.
And we're talking about not just masonry, we're talking about block wall.
There's I would say the majority of cities in America.
You wouldn't even know what I was talking about because it's it's
the ugliest fence in the world, but for its climates like Vegas,
St. George, Utah, Phoenix, Arizona, they make us put these ratchet
looking block walls like we're in a prison.
And it's just the way that people do it.
And so I went sub niche.
This thing was making me over twelve hundred dollars.
I think we ended up doing it.
It's like eight hundred dollars a month now, but this thing's ranking so well.
I don't think we even have to run much ads, if any at all.
These sites, these pictures are garbage.
Some of these pictures actually go down a little bit like those ones right there.
I actually that top right one, Francesc and the bottom right one.
Francesca actually took that photo.
She actually drove to a job site, took that photo.
So that's insane.
So, you know, guys, what's cool about that is within that within block wall.
I mean, obviously, as Nick was talking about, if you go to niche,
then there's not enough volume, it's too targeted, it's too specialized.
But now even within here, there's even sub niches within block wall.
Now it's low competitive enough where you can get all those sub niches
within the sub niche of block wall.
It just goes to show it's an endless combination.
Cinder block retaining wall in Vegas.
Dude, I'm making I mean, dude, you can go.
And again, sub niche in big cities works.
OK, we got five minutes.
You can un-share this just to give you guys an example.
And let's go through a couple of questions really quick.
And we had a couple of people.
So this was this was from Christopher.
This was in earlier what you were talking about.
He said, thought I'd saw you made some big money in basement waterproofing.
I think that was a YouTube video you did like last year that talked about.
You got a deal that got lucky, right.
And then, OK, that's right.
You can go into it if you want.
It's competitive, bro.
Very, very. You can make money, just not.
You can make more money elsewhere.
I don't think it's worth the squeeze. That's just my opinion.
I'm going to I'm going to do rapid fire on these Q&A.
Keep going. Cool.
Jen said, would you please repeat the niches?
You said you got your butt kicked in real quick.
I'll we'll be putting this in that cheat sheet real quick.
But I mean, you talk about like roofing, basement waterproofing.
There's like two others there.
Solar.
Alarm systems, CPA.
Yeah, I mean, dude, just anything that plumbing HVAC,
anything that's just very obvious is competitive.
OK, for sure.
And then, yeah, Jason mentioned flat roofing, roofing tile repair,
just as some niches within roofing, which is 100 percent right on.
And then Jensen, what do you charge for St.
George Blackwall? You says a thousand or twelve hundred.
It was twelve hundred when I started.
I think our current time, I wanted to log into my start.
Oh, actually, I might be able to hold on.
Keep going. And I'm going to look this up.
I'll come back. I'm going to see if I can find it real quick.
OK, yeah. She says.
Or what did you charge in the beginning?
I don't know if this is still an active deal you have, but let's see.
No, I still do. I think it's 800 now, by the way.
I just opened up Stripe and I love it's not much.
But I just as well, I was sleeping even better.
I made one hundred and fifty bucks sleeping last night.
That's kind of cool.
That's for epoxy, by the way.
So keep going.
I just had to just every time I see it, it just makes me happy.
For sure. Jaleel says quick question for later.
How one would you introduce yourself to a prospect when cold calling?
If they don't ask, what's your connection to the lead?
So, Jaleel, if you are you talking about like when you call the lead,
we just called your your phone number or the business owner who you're prospecting.
Because we can give you a quick little answer.
That's a next.
Make some YouTube videos on that.
But it's a good question.
We can quickly address that.
Shane Noble says, do the business owner.
So, yeah, what you do is and Nick actually has a couple of videos on this,
but you pretty much you almost act like the customer start
because you got to get your foot in the door.
You can't just say, hey, are you interested in concrete leads?
You got to say, hey, do you guys do concrete in XYZ city?
Right. Kind of make it sound like you live there. Right.
And then they're going to be you keep going on like, OK, do you do cover the zip code?
You can even get specific. Right.
And then they'll probably ask like, OK, so is this for you or like, yeah,
we can give you a free estimate next week or whatever the case may be.
And that's when you transition to like, oh, it's not for me.
I just got this guy, Bob, who's looking to have a new driveway installed
and just want to make sure it's something you do before wasted any of your time.
Right. And then they don't know what to think.
Or is this a referral friend or whatever?
Now you kind of got some open time before they just click hang up on you.
And that's when you transition to, hey, man, so I got these leads coming in.
I'm looking for someone to send them to.
I wasn't happy to give you a couple for free.
And then all I ask is just later have a conversation
to see about an ongoing partnership.
Like, in short, that's the cold call. Right.
So good. Obviously, there's variables.
But by the way, real quick, I just looked it up.
I just text Francesca about St. George.
But I know we have a couple of different websites
specifically targeting block wall.
And one of them were making three hundred dollars a week.
One of them were making two hundred and twelve dollars a week
just to kind of put it in context.
So there's money in it.
There's definitely money.
Let's go through a couple more. For sure.
So, yeah, Shane says, do you do service pages when you do sub niches?
Yeah. Look at my St. George block wall.
Yeah. It was like cinder blocks, retaining walls, brick masonry, stone mason.
Like all these are block wall related.
I always do a couple of service pages.
I usually do three to five service pages no matter what. Right.
Just helps with ranking.
Plus you get more leads for a bigger piece of the pie.
So. All right. And then Jose says, I already have a roofing site and GMB.
If I change that to roof repair only, well, I mess everything up.
Yeah. With GMB, especially.
Yeah. And it's not so it keep the domain the same,
but you're going to have to go change your title.
You're going to get your page title, your meta description,
all your bolded stuff, your categories, your service pages.
You're better off just starting fresh.
But if the question is, do you already have leads coming in
or are you just trying to write games?
If you have leads coming in and you figured out a rank by all means,
we're trying to avoid having a bunch of extra work.
But if you've been like me and you're dumb enough that you kept doing it
and you ranked great, there's money in it.
It's just it's not worth the squeeze. Right.
For sure. This is like one more question from Jen.
She says, how many leads do you get for the block wall sites?
Interested in how that relates to pricing?
Real quick, I can obviously you'll toss in your two cents.
But we typically like to when this actually what you teach, Nick.
But like when you look at the lead value calculator,
you go to like MyLeadCalculator.com, whatever we want to price stuff
so that at the low the worst case scenario or like on a minimum,
we want to at least double or at least triple their profit.
Right. Like on the low end, be conservative.
And so all you got to do that, it's really not a pay per lead basis.
Obviously, I mean, you can do the calculation. Right.
But with stuff like this, generally speaking,
that concrete artificial grass, bigotry service jobs,
if Nick correct me if I'm wrong, generally 10 to 15 leads
is like kind of what you got to aim for to charge at least
a thousand fifteen hundred a month.
Yeah, as long as the niche, as long as they're making,
you know, roughly, I would say with block wall, maybe slightly more.
But yeah, it all just depends on the size of the niche, the profit margins.
And yeah, the rule of thumb is we want to at least double
on a conservative with a conservative number.
But yeah, I never give guarantees.
And typically my websites, I kind of like even though I don't say it out loud,
I kind of lead them to believe like we're not going to get any more
than 10 to 15 leads tops.
And then I go in and I smash it for him.
I know that site gets like
30 leads a month. It has been for a while.
And I know that because it's been I've had that I've had.
I've had to change clients because my client joined my program
and stopped by my leads, which is ironic.
But I replaced them.
And we've had that site go lives in 2019.
Awesome, dude. One more question.
Yeah. So Shane has to hop off.
Great to have you on, Shane.
Trey says, what do you tell the lead when you don't have the business
to say you work with for?
That's a great question, Trey.
Usually just Nick always says this, like, take control,
tell them what they want to hear.
So when you answer, just you move the process along.
You're the one who is controlling things like, hey, Bob, so I missed a call.
We missed a call. You're looking for a concrete estimate.
Like, yeah. So like, OK, what I'm going to do is I'm going to quickly get your info.
The business owner, he's on the field right now.
But later today, when he's available,
we're going to call you back and that way we can schedule an estimate.
Right. And that's when you'll do the three way.
Just use the term business owner.
You don't need to box yourself in. OK.
Aaron, real quick, before we get to the last question,
I want you to share the digital landlords application link.
And I'm going to tell you why we're going to be doing.
I had this crazy idea and I'm going to be
I haven't decided if I'm going to be taking one or two people.
But basically, long story short is we're going to be doing something
that's kind of outside the box by with inside of digital landlords.
It's going to be by application and qualification only.
So if you apply for digital landlords,
we'll probably run you through what I'm talking about here.
That doesn't necessarily mean we'll choose you.
But it's going to be very we're going to be doing something
really interesting with one or two people.
Basically, long story short, I'm not going to tell you all the details,
but we're we're almost going to handhold you to getting your first deal.
And it's it's going to be unique.
You are going to have to do something in exchange.
But for those of you that are like a little bit nervous or whatever, this
like I'm basically going to make sure that you guys get a deal.
So for those of you that are on the fence, I just want to
I haven't talked about it much on this call at all.
But Aaron just dropped a link.
If you guys value your time and you're like, hey, these calls are great.
I'm tired. Like some of you guys that are sitting here
just waiting for free information.
Now you've waited six weeks.
You should have had to do if you were in the program,
you could have had a deal by now. Right.
But you're you're getting dribbled content and we're still talking about niches.
Right. Because I can't cover everything in these calls.
So anyway, here's the heads up.
If that's something you've been on the fence about, I would apply right now
because I have something really interesting.
And it's we're going to be doing that either this week or next week.
So mention this, what I just mentioned.
And I will anyway, it's it's it's it's very interesting.
Any if everyone is called would find it interesting.
So just a heads up. OK, one more question.
Yeah, let's see.
Trey says this is the last question.
Have you heard of anyone having luck in saltwater aquarium niche?
No, but why not?
You could do like fish tank installation, maybe like for artsy, fartsy, rich.
For sure, bro. Like when I was in pool installation, guys,
I had a website in Vegas, fiberglass drop in pools.
So it's not landscaping, it's pools, it's not just pools, it's
it's it's prefab pools, it's not just prefab pools,
it's fiberglass prefab pools in Vegas.
And the guys pay me two thousand bucks a month.
Say less, Nick, say less.
Guys, thanks for being on the call.
Did you get a screenshot of everyone's on this call right now?
Doing it right now. Thanks for the reminder.
If you're on this call, you get the camera on,
you're going to get a nice little nicely packaged digital resource
that Aaron's going to put together today from my notes.
And you're going to get that DM to you.
And with that said, guys, again, if you're somebody, it's like, hey,
I'm tired of like once you guys it clicks for you guys,
that time is not coming back.
You're not getting it back.
Then you'll start to realize that who gives a rat's turd about money?
You can always make the money back, dude.
That money I spent to launch my program, dude, you know, it's funny about that.
Well, people don't realize
that guy that I that trained me on how to launch a program.
I bought that in 2021. Ten thousand bucks.
Never met the guy. I was in Dubai for a month.
Dude moved to Dubai and I hit him up.
I was like, hey, bro, I want you to know my first year,
I made a million bucks following your training, which is true, by the way.
And dude, he had me on his podcast, which is going to release here
in the next couple of weeks.
You don't you don't realize sometimes the club like this is a thing
people don't talk about. You want to get close to somebody, go buy their stuff.
I wasn't doing it for that intention, but this guy had me on his show.
I've got his personal cell phone number.
The guy takes over 10 million dollars a year.
It's just, dude, so that's pay to play.
Just I'm just saying it's just a side thing.
So anyway, that's it, guys.
Thanks for being on the call.
We'll see you guys next week.
Thanks, Aaron. Take care, guys.